mortar ET salut thomas latin one we
think that's we think it's latin right
is that it's a plan is okay okay so this
is um this is an episode i kiss this is
their version gladiator sort of um where
they house he called the fight King
fight King that's how can I forget a
name like that the fight K so we get our
King that's kind of cool
and they go in they know it's gonna be a
trap but they don't care they just want
to go on a cool adventure and they go in
it is a trap and Jake wants to make a
lava hoop hula hoop yes so he wants to
dig for lava so King goes out that he
keeps fighting and he gets these
branches of boredom that seems to make
him insane every single time he fights
these ghost gladiators so he fights them
off gets more and more hungry for like
you know and vengeance and death and
meeting the ghosts on that meat and all
these ghost gladiators are like always
crying I the only thing I could assume
is like maybe it's their take I'm like
Greek mythology heroes and stuff because
they're always tragedies most of the
time so they're always crying to
somebody so that that's kind of my
interpretation um and at the end Jake
comes up and the Vikings as you know you
have to kill your best friend and fit
doesn't even bat an eye
tries to kill him and says if I need a
bigger sword and the king gives him his
sword he destroys it which turns out
what's the source of all his power and
it was all part of Finn's plan and then
they think everybody's happy and they
get sucked into something and it just
stops um so I'll just ask you now if you
know is that ever answer what they're
sucked into well when you say they what
do you mean by they I mean like the the
kingdom and the ghosts oh no if the
ghosts just kind of float off into well
you do find out where they do float to
okay that is named later on I think just
the Colosseum itself this kind of
vanished because it's no longer has any
relevancy to what was going on it's
like they're building up to something
like some kind of joke play something
that's gonna come because they're like
yeah oh I bet they're traveling like
their best bros or whatever and we set
them free yeah and they're like the
sound and everything got like it sound
like some sort of foreshadowing thing
going on or something
I don't know it just sounded very
menacing whatever it was and if for
anything else just to make the joke a
little to make it a joke that like we
did something good and it sounded like
something horrible was happening yeah um
but you don't know what so yeah I mean
it's it's Qi I like the design of the
fight King yeah and that giant sword
that reaches to the ground even though
he's in this high it's a super high
chair I like he's missing an arm and I
like so the weird way don't you know
that was kind of fun um I the one thing
I do kind of like that at first so surly
that that's a little weird but I I got
really liking it was that you know Finn
does get very blood hungry in this and
he just wants the violence and the
reason I like that is because I think a
lot of kids could watch the show and
just sort of be like well I want to go
fight things I want to go and fight and
even though for the most part they make
it clear it's probably good to show this
is the extreme of only wanting violence
word
Finn and Jake are very much they want to
help you yeah you know and yes they like
the adventure they like having fun and
stuff but the key thing is saving people
helping people solving problems and
stuff like that and really having fun
with it so I like what happens if you
take that element away and they show it
and very negative lie where it's even
though they are kind of going in for
that reason though they're not really
going in to hurt anything they're going
to have fun going in for an adventure
yeah you know and even the ghosts are
already dead you know I mean so it's
like and they set them free and there
you go they're they're still helping out
um and the way your think it comes to
mind is the I get it maybe it's just me
man I'm just really conservative about
this kind of stuff but man was this
violent like I know there goes but like
you frickin chops off the head of one
and there's like this black
coming I'm just like Jesus that's pretty
good and like they're crying at the time
like a slice I was like yikes well I
don't find it that violent is you do I
mean yes I guess it's violent but
they're ghosts there's no actual good
and show that was that's the only way I
can figure they got around is because
they say it's ghost um
but Sammy there's one that's like its
head is cut down the middle and stuff
like that is to walk it right it gets
pretty like I said like if I was a kid I
could probably handle a find and stuff
but I know I could feel like it's just
going like you know a but again I think
because they do have that out no no
there goes they can do whatever you know
and so forth but doesn't help them to
constantly cry well one thing I love
about it is that you know Finn and Jake
obviously know it's a trap and they knew
exactly what's gonna happen what I like
is is when they're fighting in there in
the pair's
the ghosts are always in the pair's and
they're always apologizing hmm they're
apologizing to someone they're always
saying these names and you never know
who it is
and at the end when they show them
walking in pairs it shows that okay
throughout this entire like existence of
this Coliseum best friends brothers
companions have always been kind of like
drawn in there and forced to kill each
other that's why they're crying and
apologizing it's to their companion oh
okay I'm sorry I failed you I'm sorry I
you know forgive me forgive me for what
I've done
okay you know I actually didn't but that
seems very frigging obvious now but yeah
I'm actually I did not put that together
that you're good playing well of course
you see all the skeletons at the bottom
you know these sync them down you know
it's like the corpses of them are well
yeah sure but yeah okay and then what
makes sense what the names are they're
just saying the name of the other person
yeah they killed their um so that's kind
of that's pretty that's pretty intense I
just I just love the the scene though
where finish like trying to kill Jake
and he's like and you said it before but
I love the way that Finn just
and he's like I can't do it I can't kill
my best friend and he drops the sword
and you know that's when you expect the
whole like he's my best friend I could
never do this he's like I can't kill him
without a bigger sword you know you
wanna know how I knew that was still
gonna keep going though I think this is
sort of like a cartoon trick or whatever
is that the I was still teaching yeah
yeah that's very crack died now of
course he's faking it anyway yeah but
yeah at the same time I'm like oh I know
we can go for this but I didn't see that
he was going to use that like he was
faking it the whole time I didn't draw
that conclusion so I like that I like
that they do always sort of keep you
guessing like that don't exactly know
where they're gonna go
go with it it was fun I liked it yeah
that actually adds a whole new level to
it like I said that you're right it must
have been friends that went in together
and then they had to end up killing each
other and they didn't obsessed or
whatever yeah but I wonder it was there
actually anything - the branches of
Boreham whatever they were and like if
he ate them like did that happen with
the other two as well or was it just
that they couldn't leave until they kill
one another sort of thing I see I almost
just the branches as something different
as in because when he throws it
initially to fit in Jake Jake doesn't
even bother touching it and Finn's like
oh sweet this is kind of a sucky gift
but awesome I'll take it anyways I think
it was almost the level of like greed
that may come into play something so
minor as a branch of sin becoming so
important to the point where like you're
consuming it so no one else can have it
yeah like it's not necessarily like the
branch was doing anything necessarily to
Finn or the other people it was merely
the idea of victory
yeah and having them constantly fight
more and more people I will say this the
episode probably would have been a
little stronger because he went through
like what about four or five different
duo's of glitter it probably would have
been stronger if you got the idea like
he was doing it over a long Syria I mean
that's how the other gladiators got into
that you know blood hunger - is that you
get in such a repetition that way say
now kill your friend or whatever
okay it's like you're just so into it
you've been doing for so long I mean you
could do it where it's like dozens upon
dozens or even hundreds or whatever I
mean you can do anything with the
venture time yeah it probably probably
well worked a little better it still got
across I mean if I but I think it does
make it even more sad when you realize
like if they emphasize how many people
came in and this happened to like what
would have been nice for me and the only
downer or part that I was not too hugely
fond of is there are certain scenes work
focused on Jake just doing his dance
which was funny but then I was kind of
like okay let's kind of do a little
something else you know yeah the whole
there's I know it sounds strange because
I know it's a show of like randomness
and strangeness but I thought there was
something even more random and strange
that Jake could have been yeah
especially cuz the episode is so gray
and it's so the colors are not very
bright in it which is fine everyone so
loud but like you said when you had to
cut back to hey this is the goofy silly
part going on now with Jake you can make
it even more goofy and silly like the
mermaid fin made out of the dirt and the
sea yeah but it was mainly just him
dancing what would have been nice was
along with what you were saying have a
split screen object doing his weird
dance and fin consistently fighting and
fighting and fighting yeah like that
because I'm even showing them more and
more than he goes through yeah stuff
like that or if he actually found the
lava hula-hoop just like something comes
I think a point where he was starting to
dig up at the ML sort of like yeah okay
kind of seen the sea you know I met
maybe something a little punch here but
I mean again from a show that is so good
at keeping us guessing and three
surprises at us I mean it's like that's
a minor thing to get ahead about but but
yeah I kind of agree that was or the
point where it's like okay what's going
on the surface again you know so but ya
know I liked it and like I said well you
brought up with the you know that this
is that you've been going on for years
and different new ones going in I think
and she does make it more interesting so
yeah good episode
anything else do we have to fight each
other now only if we can film it
can we do it with the camera just
sitting there do we need some day so we
walk around no I don't think you get it
the camera is my weapon Oh